was a double piece sacrificed by the
15th world champion playing very
aggressively and now Knight F5 on the
board attacking the black king but it's
very interesting what Anand has in mind
after Bishop E6
even he takes on G7 and the queen H6 but
Bishop G4 what what can you do what what
can you oh yeah Bishop F6 oh wait Knight
on G7
wow sacrificing a rook and a piece that
will be made on G7 what can you do with
black hair well
yes Rook E6 seems to be a move Look H4
is possible Bishop AJ oh
wow
look at that cool move the bishop is
would be hanging but the Rook is hanging
everything is hanging and it's made on
G7 and now there is nothing to be done
beautiful it's game over what a
beautiful game by the 15th world
champion